et
[Musique]
pendant que les essais shadoks continue
à rater les jbe surveillent leur jardin
à instruments et on est emporté les
haines d'instruments pour les replanter
sur la terre et en attendant auquel
mûrissent pour passer le temps ils le
regardaient les essais shadoks ratés et
les essais de fusées shadoks comporter
plusieurs farce
d'abord les techniciens chats 2 cantonne
le compte à rebours sur un vieil air
d'accordéon
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]
et puis les shadoks les plus doués pour
les mathématiques enfourchent leur
ordinateur à pédales pour calculer la
toile
c'étaient eux qui avaient le plus de mal
qu'à les shadoks avait entendu dire que
plus un ordinateur va vite plus il donne
de bons résultats et c'est celui qui
avait gagné qui avait trouvé la bonne
trajectoire
on procédait alors à la mise à feu a
raté une petite oie après on
recommençait naturellement on pourrait
continuer comme ça pendant longtemps
mais
[Musique]